O
STATE OF THE UNION. THIS WEEK,
DONALD TRUMP BECAME THE FIRST
FORMER PRESIDENT INDICTED ON
CRIMINAL CHARGES. SO WHAT IS IT
MEANS FOR HIS BIGGEST SUPPORTERS
? WHAT DO THEY THINK? WELL,
POLLSTER FRANK LUNTZ AND
STRAIGHT ARROW NEWS CONVENED A
FOCUS GROUP OF TRUMP BACKERS
THIS WEEK. TAKE A LISTEN TO THE
ADVICE THEY HAD FOR THE FORMER
PRESIDENT. IF DONALD TRUMP ARE
LISTENING TO THIS FOCUS GROUP
RIGHT NOW. WHAT WOULD YOU TELL
HIM? FOCUS ON WHAT'S GOING ON IN
THIS COUNTRY STOP TARGETING
DESANTIS AND START TARGETING
BIDEN. THAT'S THE GUY THAT YOU
WANT OUT OF OFFICE. TELL TRUMP
THAT HIS FELLOW REPUBLICANS ARE
NOT HIS ENEMIES DO NOT GO TO THE
GUTTER AVOIDED, IT TURNS OFF THE
VOTERS WOULD TELL HIM THAT AS
PRESIDENT, HE HAD GREAT POLICIES
HE NEEDS TO LEARN TO PICK HIS
BATTLES. AND WE ARE BACK WITH
OUR PANEL. THANK YOU FOR ALL FOR
COMING IN ONE AND ALL THE
SENATOR SCOTT BROWN. YOU WORKED
FOR DONALD TRUMP. YOU WERE HIS
AMBASSADOR TO TERRIBLE, TERRIBLE
JOB IN NEW ZEALAND. WHAT'S YOUR
REACTION TO THE NEWS THIS WEEK?
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S A POLITICAL
ANALYSIS AND THEN THERE'S A
LEGAL ANALYSIS. I MEAN, YOU LOOK
AT THE ANTI TRUMPERS ROMNEY
BOLTON. YEAH AND THEN YOU LOOK
AT SOME OF YOUR OWN. IT JUST
TOOK A NOTE ON. YOU KNOW, ELLIE
AND THEN MCCABE AND VAN JONES
BASICALLY SAYING THAT, YOU KNOW,
IT'S INEXPLICABLE, INEXPLICABLE
THE CASE THAT WAS ACTUALLY
BRIGHT SOME CONCERNS AS ALL THE
POLITICAL ANALYSIS ANALYSIS
FOLKS DO ABOUT THE STATUE OF
LIMITATIONS, TAKING A STATE
CRIME AND TURNING INTO A FEDERAL
CRIME, SO HE'S GOT SOME
CHALLENGES THERE, BUT THE
POLITICAL SIDE OF IT. YEAH IT
GIVES THEM A BUMP. YOU CAN TELL
FROM THE FOLKS THAT ARE RIGHT
THERE AND WE JUST HEARD GIVES
THEM A LITTLE BUMP. BUT CAN YOU
SUSTAIN IT? HE'S GOT TO FOCUS ON
PEOPLE. THE ISSUE IS NOT
HIMSELF, AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
WE JUST HEARD FROM THESE TRUMP
VOTERS. THIS FOCUS GROUP THAT
FRANKLIN'S DEAD FASCINATING. I'M
SURE YOU HAVE SIMILAR
CONVERSATIONS AS A POLLSTER. ONE
THING THAT I THINK IS SO
INTERESTING ABOUT WHAT THESE
VOTERS WERE SAYING IN THIS FOCUS
GROUP IS THAT THEY DON'T WANT
DONALD TRUMP GOING AFTER FOLKS
LIKE RON DESANTIS. WHAT'S ALWAYS
BEEN TOUGH FOR ANY OF THESE
OTHER REPUBLICANS IN THE FIELD.
IS THE ASYMMETRY OF DONALD TRUMP
CAN TAKE A SWING AT THEM AND
PEOPLE GO. WELL. THAT'S JUST HOW
DONALD TRUMP IS. HE JUST LIKES
TO THROW PUNCHES. BUT IF YOU'RE
ANYBODY ELSE AND YOU CRITICIZE
TRUMP, THEN SUDDENLY EVERYBODY
GOES. OH GOSH, YOU CAN'T. WHY
WOULD YOU ATTACK SOMEONE ELSE
WITHIN THE OWN PARTY AND SO TO
HEAR THEM ACTUALLY SAYING NO, I
DON'T WANT YOU. DONALD TRUMP
ATTACKING OTHER REPUBLICANS IS
INTERESTING. IT SUGGESTS. MAYBE
THAT ASYMMETRY IS LESS PRESENT.
MAYBE THERE IS MORE ROOM FOR
SOMEONE LIKE A DESANTIS OR NIKKI
HALEY OR WHATEVER TO TAKE A
LITTLE BIT TOO. NEEDLE DONALD
TRUMP A LITTLE BIT MORE FASHION
CARE. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
COMING. WELCOME TO THE TO THE
STATE OF UNION ROUNDTABLE. YOU
WORKED FOR BERNIE SANDERS AS A
SENIOR ADVISER. YOU KNOW
SOMETHING ABOUT FIGHTING IN A
PRIMARY. YEAH THERE'S SUPPOSED
TO BE GOOD FIGHTS IN PRIMARIES.
I FEEL LIKE YOU KNOW, I'M
WATCHING WHAT'S GOING ON THE
RIGHT, THOUGH, AND YOU'RE
FEELING LIKE A LOSS OF MORAL
CONVERSATION. YOU USED TO HAVE
MORAL CONVERSATION IN POLITICS.
YOU HAVE LEGAL CONVERSATIONS. I
APPRECIATE THAT. THERE'S
CONCERNS OVER WHETHER THE CASE
AND THE STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS
AND OTHER ISSUES ARE AT PLAY.
BUT WHAT HAPPENED TO MORAL
LEADERSHIP? DOES ANYONE GET
CONCERNED THAT A PRESIDENT WHO
HAD AN AFFAIR WITH US PORN STAR
WALL HIS WIFE JUST GAVE BIRTH,
DIDN'T PAID HER A BUNCH OF MONEY
TO TRY TO WIN AN ELECTION AND
TURN OFF. YOU KNOW, A POTENTIAL
ISSUE THAT WOULD HAVE KILLED HIM
IN A PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION? NO
NO, IT'S DRUG. AND I THINK AT
THAT POINT YOU'RE WONDERING
WHERE IS MORAL LEADERSHIP EVEN
FROM PEOPLE ON THE RIGHT. SAY
OKAY, I HAVE CONCERNS WITH LEGAL
ISSUES, HOWEVER. MORALLY THIS IS
JUST NOT ACCORDED WITH MY VALUES
. AND WHAT HAPPENED TO THAT?
WHAT HAPPENED TO THAT KIND OF
CONVERSATION ON THE RIGHT SAILED
A LONG TIME AGO, RIGHT? I MEAN,
EVER SINCE 2016. IT WAS VERY
CLEAR. THIS IS A DIFFERENT
REPUBLICAN PARTY AND THEY WERE
INTERESTED AND MASSIVE POWER AT
ALL COSTS AND ALL THAT MORALITY
TALK THAT WE LIVED THROUGH IN
THE NINETIES AND IN THE
EIGHTIES, IT'S GONE. WELL
RESPECTFULLY, BILL CLINTON, GARY
HART. LET'S NOT TAKE THE MORAL
ISSUE AND ALL OF A SUDDEN THINK
IT'S NEW. THERE'S BEEN
INDISCRETIONS BY PREVIOUS
PRESIDENTS, PRESIDENTS. MY
CONCERN IS THAT YOU'RE OPENING
UP IN THE FORM OF PANDORA'S BOX.
THIS HAS NEVER HAPPENED IN OUR
COUNTRY'S HISTORY TO TAKE
SOMETHING THAT'S A STATE ISSUE
MORE FIT AFTER THE STATUE OF
LIMITATIONS PASSES INTO A
FEDERAL ISSUE. WHAT HAPPENS IF
IT'S GOING TO HAVE A RED STATE D
A. ALL OF A SUDDEN WANTS TO TAKE
ON ONE OF YOURS? IS THAT WHERE
WE'RE GOING NOW IT'S GOING TO
DISCOURAGE PEOPLE FROM RUNNING
WHO ARE LEGITIMATELY READY TO
SERVE THIS COUNTRY AND IT'S
GOING TO CREATE PROBLEMS DOWN
THE ROAD YOU INTO THIS DEGREE OF
MORAL RELATIVITY, AND I
APPRECIATE THE POINT THAT THAT
YOU KNOW, HIS CONDUCT MAY BE
JUST AS BAD AS THIS PERSON
CONDUCT WOULD. I WOULD ARGUE MY
OWN PERSPECTIVE IS THAT HIS
CONDUCT LIVES IN A RAIN OF ITS
OWN PEOPLE THAT INTO ACCOUNT
WHEN THEY VOTED FOR HIM. THEY
KNEW ABOUT ALL HIS INDISCRETIONS
INTO ALL ABOUT HIS PROBLEMS.
THEY COMPARED AND MEASURED
BETWEEN HIM AND HILLARY AND THEY
CHOSE HIM. GOD HIMSELF MOVING
FORWARD. LISTEN, YOU HAVE A NEW
CYCLE COMING UP. DOES HE HAVE
ISSUES TO OVERCOME? ABSOLUTELY
BUT SO DOES JOE BIDEN AT 42% AND
ALL THE THINGS THAT ARE
HAPPENING WITH HIM, ONE OF THE
ISSUES THAT WE SAW THIS WEEK
THAT'S STILL PROVES VERY
POWERFUL. AMONG VOTERS IS THE
ISSUE OF ABORTION, PARTICULARLY
IN IN SWING STATES. WE SAW WHAT
HAPPENED IN WISCONSIN. NOW WE
HAVE THIS RULING THAT WE TALKED
ABOUT EARLIER IN THE SHOW. THERE
WAS ONE JUDGE IN TEXAS THERE WAS
A SPLIT RULING, BUT THE TEXAS
JUDGE JUDGE SAID HE WAS GOING TO
REVOKE THE FDA APPROVED APPROVAL
OF AN ABORTION. BILL. UM HOW
MUCH DO YOU THINK THIS IS GOING
TO? I MEAN, OBVIOUSLY THE SHORT
TERM. THIS IS THE POLICY, BUT
LET'S JUST TALK POLITICS HERE.
HOW IS THIS GOING TO PLAY INTO
THE POLITICAL LANDSCAPE? I MEAN,
IT'S GOING TO BE HUGE YOU'VE
SEEN EVER SINCE LAST YEAR IN
NOVEMBER, AND WITH WISCONSIN,
LIKE THE VOTERS ARE NOT
INTERESTED IN HAVING GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS OR JUDGES TAKE AWAY
THEIR RIGHTS. THIS AND LET'S
TALK ABOUT WHAT THIS DRUG IS A
DRUG HAS BEEN USED FOR OVER TWO
DECADES. THAT IS SAFER THAN
TYLENOL. THIS THIS RULING HAS
RAMIFICATIONS WAY BEYOND
ABORTION. YOU ARE LOOKING AT THE
LEGITIMACY OF THE FDA AND HOW
THEY APPROVED MEDICINE. LIKE
WHAT? WHAT'S TO SAY THEY'RE
GOING TO STOP HERE. SO WHAT
YOU'RE SEEING IS THIS HYPER
RADICALIZATION OF JUDICIAL
SYSTEM THAT'S PLAYING OUT AND I
THINK THE POLITICS OF IT ARE
GOING TO BE BAD FOR THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY, BUT THE POLICY
OF IT SHOULD TERRIFY EVERYBODY
WHO CARES ABOUT SCIENCE AND
INDEPENDENCE. WHAT I'M SEEING IN
A LOT OF MY DATA IS THAT FOR
THOSE VOTERS WHO ARE PRO CHOICE,
THEY ARE MUCH MORE FIRED UP
ABOUT THE ISSUE OF ABORTION
RIGHT NOW THAN VOTERS WHO ARE
PRO LIFE. FRANKLY IN THE DATA
YOU DO NOT SEE PRO LIFE VOTERS
SAYING, HEY, WE SCORED VICTORIES
HERE. WE FEEL MOMENTUM. WE'RE
GONNA VOTE ON THESE ISSUES.
INSTEAD, IT IS MUCH MORE LIKELY
TO HAVE A NEGATIVE EFFECT ON
REPUBLICANS, AT LEAST IN THE
SHORT TERM AT THE BALLOT BOX.
AND I THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT HAS BEEN KIND OF,
YOU KNOW, OPENED UP BY THE
RULING IN DOBBS LAST SUMMER IS
THAT IT PUT THE ISSUE BACK IN
THE FOREFRONT OF THE POLITICAL
CONVERSATION IN A WAY THAT IT
WASN'T PRIOR TO THE RULING. BUT
THAT IS PRIMARILY A CONVERSATION
THAT DEMOCRATIC ACTIVISTS ARE
HAPPY TO HAVE. WHILE REPUBLICANS
. IT'S THE THIRD OR FOURTH TIER
ISSUE FOR MANY REPUBLICANS WANT
TO TURN TO THE SITUATION IN
TENNESSEE? THESE TWO LAWMAKERS,
STATE LAWMAKERS WHO DEMOCRATS
WHO ARE EXPELLED BECAUSE THEY
PROTESTED ON THE FLOOR OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN FAVOR OF GUN
REFORM. LET'S LISTEN TO WHAT ONE
OF THEM SAID. WE'RE BEING
SPILLED, NOT BECAUSE OF CRIME,
NOT BECAUSE OF THE ETHICS
VIOLATION BECAUSE WE STOOD WITH
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE
DEMANDING THAT WE ACT STUDENTS
AND RATHER THAN ADDRESS THE
ISSUE OF BANNING ASSAULT
WEAPONS, MY FORMER COLLEAGUES,
REPUBLICAN MAJORITY ARE
ASSAULTING DEMOCRACY AND THAT
SHOULD THAT SHOULD SCARE ALL OF
US ACROSS THE NATION. CAN YOU.
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE IN TODAY'S
SOCIETY, AND I THINK UNDER I
WOULD BLAME TRUMP AGAIN. IS THAT
THAT KIND OF POLITICS OF BLOOD
SPORT THAT IF YOU DISAGREE WITH
ME, HERE COMES THE FIREHOSE OF
VENOM. ANGER, VITRIOL,
RETRIBUTION WERE TEARING YOU
DOWN RATHER THAN TO SAY. I
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE, AND I
DON'T SAY THAT THE LEFT IS
IMMUNE FROM THIS AT ALL. BUT I
DO THINK THAT THE RIGHT
DISCOURSE IS ONE OF SAYING YOU
DISAGREE. HERE COMES A PUNCH IN
YOUR HEAD ON A LEGISLATURE AND
BERNIE, I RESPECT THEM BOTH RUN
21 TIMES. IT'S BEEN A BLOOD
SPORT. SINCE I RAN FOR ASSESSOR
, YOU KNOW, ALMOST 30 YEARS AGO
. IT'S ALWAYS BEEN A BLOOD SPORT
THAT BEING SAID, YOU HAVE A
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS WHERE PEOPLE
VOTED IN A DEMOCRATIC MANNER,
AND NOW IT'S BEING CALLED ON
DEMOCRATIC WHAT THEY DID.
HOWEVER LISTEN. IT'S EASTER,
RAMADAN AND PASSOVER RIGHT NOW.
I DON'T DISAGREE WITH YOU THAT
WE SHOULD FIND COMMON GROUND
BECAUSE THIS IS A VERY, VERY
SERIOUS ISSUE. WHAT'S GOING ON
WITH GUN VIOLENCE AROUND THIS
COUNTRY? BUT YOU DON'T CONDUCT
THAT EXPELLED. LET ME FINISH. WE
HAVE DECORUM RULES AS A STATE.
REP STATE SENATOR, US SENATOR
AMBASSADOR MILITARY YOU DON'T GO
IN THE HOUSE FLOOR AND START
BANGING AND TAKING OVER THEIR
HOLD ON SHOULD EXACTLY EXACTLY
RIGHT. SHOULD YOU HAVE EXPELLED
THEM? NO. I DISAGREE WITH THAT.
I THINK THERE'S A WAY TO FIND
THAT COMMON GROUND. LET THEM
HAVE THEIR BULLY PULPIT. YOU'VE
RAISED THEM ALMOST TO MARTYR
LEVEL NOW AND NOW, OBVIOUSLY ONE
IS GOING TO COME BACK TO THE
PROCESS. THERE WILL BE A PROCESS
AND I THINK QUITE FRANKLY, THIS
HELPS THE DEMOCRATS IN THAT
STATE. BUT LISTEN, THE DEMOCRAT
POLICIES IN THAT STATE OF SO FAR
LEFT THAT, YOU KNOW, IT REALLY
WON'T MATTER IN TENNESSEE. I
MEAN, LOOK, I'M GLAD TO HEAR
THAT. YOU THINK THAT EXPELLING
THEM WAS WAY TOO FAR? AND IF YOU
LOOK INTO THE HISTORY OF
TENNESSEE IN THAT STATE HOUSE,
LIKE THIS ACTUALLY ISN'T
SURPRISING THAT IT HAPPENED
BECAUSE EVER SINCE REPUBLICANS
HAVE GOTTEN A SUPERMAJORITY
THERE, THEY HAVE BEEN USING THAT
HAMMER AND THAT QUOTE TO VOTE TO
STOP THE SET. WHEN YOU'RE
GERRYMANDER THE STATE WITHIN AN
INCH OF ITS LIFE, IT'S HARD TO
SAY, GET OUT AND VOTE WHEN
YOU'RE SPLITTING UP DEMOCRATIC
DISTRICTS AT THE POINT WHERE
THEY DON'T HAVE THAT POWER.
MOSTLY WITH REPUBLICANS, MOSTLY
WITH REPUBLICANS HAVE TO LEAVE
IT THERE. I'M SURE THIS WILL